we just lost that right at the end of
2022 and I want to do a little obituary
for my man it was uh elephant boy died
the very famous Fred the elephant boy he
was the longest serving whack packer in
show history his real name was Fred
Schreiber and we gave him the nickname
elephant boy because he sounded like the
movie The Elephant Man here's his first
call to the show November 28 1988 over
34 years ago this was the first time we
heard you're on the air yeah oh I just
shot on my radio now what is that an
Italian accent Gary no no I smell
ratings gold with you Fred
that's good yeah see how it hey I love
you too man this guy's perfect what is
it some kind of speech defect you got oh
yes
what ever since I was born
ever since you were born you had this
problem I got you I'm catching onto your
lingo when I ran for governor on the
libertarian ticket in 1994 I knew Fred
was the perfect person to introduce me
at their convention and here he is he
came with me it's my great pleasure to
keep the nominated space too hard I
think this is the best thing I ever
happened to the Olympic game pie because
Plus have become governor of New York
yeah he he was quite the speech master
and sometimes we would hold funerals
whenever we would win in a radio market
and become number one we would have a
funeral for the DJs
that lost to us here's Fred's speech at
our 1994 Cleveland funeral I mean this
guy was a super fan listen to him he
knows how to whip a crowd into shape and
not the mama you're ready for
that one you'll get me thank you
[Applause]
I mean
you couldn't ask for a better hype man
it was a good-hearted guy and uh always
whenever you asked him to do something
he was so thrilled to be a part of the
radio show and he gave us lots of hours
of enjoyment so Fred the Elephant Boy
rest in peace we lost you in 2022.
foreign